[Music]
otherwise i'm going to make fun of your
banks the whole time
are you serious you're going through
something i mean obviously
i've said that but they do look good so
you're also dressed like john lovitz
today what's going on
what's happening i bought this shirt
before i did mushrooms and then after i
did them i got the confidence to wear it
like did you get this at a sandals
resort gift shop
kid you not i was getting dressed this
morning and i was like i have to wear
something that whitney can ridicule
otherwise she will feel
jilted and will never ask me to be on
the podcast again
i actually made her wear this i was like
wear a funny shirt so i can roast you
yeah you did you look like you're trying
to look 15. okay
i mean let's just break this down you
guys i really i
cuz i i like to you know the beginning
of podcast release all my insecurities
so that they're yours oh is that what so
you guys have to deal with i don't
listen to this
podcast not a fan i skip the first part
where it's mostly you talking
okay so i um nice try cute very cute
um i've facetimed you before and you
were in my merch so let's just
calm down taylor um it was free i'm
so i don't like you i'm just thrifting
i'm wearing a hat again today because i
have something called a smolen salivary
gland
and it makes me look like i went to joan
rivers
surgeon and i'm insecure about it people
already think
that i get a facelift once a week right
uh because i finally learned how to
contour
and i can afford good skincare yeah i'm
always shiny as fuck
so everybody thinks that i'm like just
you know gone off the rails like full
housewife
and so i'm wearing a hat a burgundy hat
to cover it up so
i'm not trying to look young
i'm trying to look less
like carrot top okay and it's making me
look
more like your top oddly i'm carrot
bottom
so i am wearing a hat uh and it does
look desperate and it does look like i'm
trying to be hip
yeah but you wore a hat on your last
episode you're wearing what i should be
wearing and i'm wearing what you should
be wearing honestly yeah
that's actually true i'm dressed like a
26 year old and you're dressed like a 38
year old
we should swap this is okay this is like
crap
i got this in an urban outfitters i'm
not going to let you make new
this isn't vintage no it isn't so she uh
so what taylor's wearing she's wearing
um have you guys seen the golden girls
couch
it's like the upholstery of the golden
girls couch and it's
in a like a button-down shirt um because
she's
fun she's trying to pretend she's fun i
i actually am i bought this i sent this
picture to like four people and was like
does this look like i'm trying to be
more fun than i am and they're like yeah
but we like it no it's good i mean it's
like um
it's like a napkin it's senor frogs
do you even know what senior frogs it's
a restaurant right yes
and you're like a waiter at dicks
supporting your personality no that
restaurant where
they you pay them to be mean to you oh
that's the whole theme of the restaurant
is we're gonna be mean to you
today i'm dressed like shawn white this
is basically the look i'm going for you
wore a beanie on the last episode i know
and i think you were like
trying to look like i don't give a shit
that an
influencer model is a guest on my
podcast i think that for me
when amanda cerny who's a very famous
model influencer came on i just i wore a
beanie because i wanted the option to be
able to pull it over my face at any
moment if i felt ugly or something
it's like a turtle just being able to
like hide in my shell and i did it a
couple times a couple times i pulled it
over my face
like like you know an ostrich puts their
head in the sand
did you really yeah i did because we did
these like prank calls and i get so
uncomfortable
around pranks i don't like i don't like
them that i just hid in my hat
oh my god i mean it was like the hot
pink i only saw the clip where she's
like you're jealous of me
oh you haven't muted me no i haven't i
will say
whitney has liked a few of my posts
since i
confronted you on your podcast
i've noticed you liked a couple of my
posts do you need me to like you
literally in favor you do you like me so
much like
i'm obsessed with you it's actually
weird it's confusing to me you told me
in denver that you
you're like well we're closer than i am
to a lot of people and i was like
what i think you and i are closer than
a lot of people that i've spent a
tremendous amount of time with i think
you and i are
really inherently close that is so
interesting because we
are the same person and that is an
insult to you
okay take that as an insult because it's
meant to be one i feel like we're so
similar in a lot of ways and then we're
like polar opposites in a lot of ways as
well
but also i'm younger and you always tell
me you were exactly like this at my age
i fee when i'm with you i feel like you
are
you are me i i feel like i'm hanging out
with myself at 26. oh my god is that so
weird it's
so fucking weird but i would never wear
that shirt
i would never would have wanted to wear
shirts like this so it is interesting
because
i think that it's most women's instinct
to be threatened by
the bitch that's nipping at her heels
and there's something kind of
fascinating about
how i've just um
pulled you into my bosom right well it
is
um it's like a very specific form of
narcissism
[Laughter]
that you found someone who threatens you
and you just went no you're me
in the past and we're gonna hang out and
i'm gonna keep a lid on you
it's like um it's like eating your the
twin that ate the other twin in the womb
like i'm just gonna fully internalize
you and consume you
but i think there's something about you
that like i just i didn't
have like a big sister in comedy
mm-hmm don't you is that a relationship
am i like your big sister
yeah you're like a big sister who never
asked me how i'm doing
unless it's being recorded
i'm teaching you how to build a brand in
a business
you actually are i do feel like a big
sister energy here and i'm
the oldest in my family of four sisters
so it's been like actually very nice
for me yeah and also yeah i do learn a
lot from you like
i think you are a very impressive
business woman
above all else you just like you're just
smart about everything
and you're not like you're not someone
in this business
who's like i'm only gonna be good at
this one thing and i'm gonna be like
totally focused on this one thing like a
lot of people are you have
sort of a million plates spinning at all
times
and like are always just you just think
about things in a really smart strategic
way
that is like give me an example
i mean can i talk about the fact that we
pitched a show yeah we sold a show
together we're making a tv show together
yes we could totally talk about this so
is this sorry i'm gonna this is what
maybe she's starting is this too wide
should this be tighter or we could
always punch in later this is me trying
to micromanage camera angles
i mean i guess we don't need it to be
that much closer but i feel like we have
a lot of
a lot of space so this is this is if you
guys want to learn about vietnam
if you want she's doing it right now
give me an example living example
whether you're giving a presentation
whether you're in a job interview
whether you're uh shooting a show
shooting your content stop and fix it
if you see something wrong just stop and
fix it thank you
um because otherwise you're gonna be
distracted and it's gonna be an elephant
in the living room and everyone else is
gonna see the thing that you don't see
so you might as well just call it out
yeah so i just did that i just adjusted
my camera angle
while taylor was talking about how good
of a um
strategic business woman i am yeah
um an example oh specifically when we
were writing the show
we like first off we finished we sold a
tv show today that's a big deal it is a
big deal thank you
um for saying that because i'm still
like it didn't happen how do you feel
about it i know you seem to have an
odd relationship with success um yeah i
don't trust it until it's like literally
happening and then when it happens you
won't trust it either because then it's
going to get taken away possibly
yes yeah because the last time i saw you
because the last time i saw your special
had not come out yet
uh the first time right last time you
were on this podcast
yes here's what i'm interested in last
time you guys had
we had taylor on this podcast heard
special not come out now it's come out
it was a big big deal did it fix
everything
are you fixed no are you healed you had
wild success
you got to work with me you had a
special come out on netflix that was
huge
thanks to the pandemic yeah and your
talent and your talent
the biggest thing that came out of that
special was you wanting to work with me
i worked with you we wrote a show
together we sold it
are you fixed are all the invisible
moons healed no oh success doesn't fix
it you know what i will say i'm not
fixed
but i am like i think much closer to
being fixed than i was before we started
working together
because this show that we were working
on the character
my character in the show is a serial
monogamous
who realizes they need to be alone for a
while
and do you know how hard it is to go to
work every day
with whitney cummings who will not
like let you even have a minute
to like do the wrong thing emotionally
and just goes like oh well you should
just be doing this
and not like be super self-reflective
like
i think i came out of writing this show
learning a lot about myself because
there were so many days that i like
pitched ideas for storylines or jokes
and you were like
this feels like something that's is that
a joke or is that just something you're
going through
yeah are we picturing non-fiction what
are we doing
so yeah i think that was a big thing but
oh specifically when we were writing the
show
we finished a draft of it and you were
like i don't know what's wrong with it
i need to sleep on it and then the next
day we came back and you said
we need to rewrite the whole thing with
these changes like but you knew it you
trust your gut enough
to go i know something's off here
whereas
i don't think i have that
trust in myself yet interesting um
i mean in my personal life or my career
i think i'm getting better at it and
you're helping me get better at trusting
my gut
and listening to myself oh you should
trust my gut not yours i mean
again sometimes you say things and i'm
like not always correct
today you need some probiotics you're
saying it like it's right
not enough people challenge you like i
love it with taylor
like i think taylor it's been funny to
watch you be sort of conditioned
to think i'm right just in terms of like
just knowing
of me and that i'm successful and
watching me from afar and then
she'll agree with me instinctively and
then i'll watch
like you know when your computer freezes
and there's that rainbow spinning wheel
and then i'll see the spinning wheel and
she goes no that's not true yeah i know
i'm supposed to believe you
yeah because you're older than me but
you don't like people disagreeing with
you
i actually i actually do if i respect
them okay i guess you don't respect me
i have gotten so many uh dms from people
both strangers and people i know when
you film me like in the bathroom or
something who go like oh my god i have
so much anxiety watching these stories
of whitney filming you because they're
like oh my god
he's just like crossing a boundary here
and i'm just like look it's fine
we're good but people have like checked
on me they're also crossing a boundary
by dming you and being worried about you
you're an adult
i get it but there there have been times
where i'm like you cannot post this and
you post it
and i'm like all right like fine i guess
i'll get more followers
jesus well it's actually i think it was
annie letterman who was like
so it is i don't i don't i want taylor
to be famous
and rich and hugely successful
you said this or anything i'm saying oh
i just said that okay that just came out
all right you started with annie so i'm
like oh no yeah and
we were doing a photo shoot at my house
i believe that taylor has some
odd body dysmorphia body shame stuff
been there
done it i'll give you my old journals if
you want to know what's coming next
that would be amazing can we start a
podcast called whitney's journal
i would fucking love to read them
they're all just like tear stained you
can't even make it out
just looks like watercolor paintings saw
another dick today
it's just doodles in the corner whitney
mathers
i wanted to be with eminem for a long
time um
and uh where am i going uh you were
going with uh you were doing a photo
shoot at your house
and i believe that taylor's body
should be public domain i
i sense some shame around your and i do
too when i
first started in being a comedian i was
very ashamed of being feminine i was
very ashamed of being a woman i was
meant to um be
uh think that it was like manipulative
or
my fault if guys thought i was hot
or i was a siren or whatever like we're
made to feel guilty for being attractive
yeah we're made to feel guilty
if we're a distraction to men it's our
fault if we're sexy and i'm just i'm
done with that shit
and anyway um and just business
101 a photo of you in the pool in this
really cute bikini
just let's get the bags and so
i put taylor on a very precarious
table meant for lacroix three
maximum it was could maybe hold us
uh spf lip balm at
on a good day we did not know this was
hollow this was a hollow
west elm side table had many a crack
yeah saw the cracks i put them i put it
in the pool
and i was like taylor needs to stand on
this and i i knew it had like
a good five to eight minutes left of
life you
knew that i felt like i felt like we
were gonna get the picture and then it
was gonna break
are you serious you knew i was gonna
break i was like i know this will
probably break but like what are the
chances it's gonna break while we're
filming
and then because god loves you oh my god
it broke while we were filming taylor
fell into it
retweeted or posted by influencers in
the wild
about a million views in the first day
didn't look at it at all because i was
like i'm gonna see a comment that hurts
my feelings
yeah oh no oh and andy letterman was
like that was the most chris jenner shit
i've ever seen
that was like brokering your sex tape
what you just did with taylor
because she was like that was really
dangerous and i was like yeah and then i
looked at my phone i was like my legs
i was like 600 000 likes it's fine and
she was like that was sociopathic
my leg was fucked up for a few weeks
fine worked for the jackass guys
this is the businesswoman thing bad
friend good business
that's your next book by the way your
last one was i'm fine the next one is
a bad friend good business woman how was
the process of writing a tv show with me
um surprisingly easy
surprisingly easy yeah i mean the same
way i felt about you being uh
you know someone that i am friends with
i'm like pleasantly surprised
okay how was it writing a tv show with
me
um because i know you don't you've told
me to keep me grateful
yeah how lucky people want to work with
me
and i know that now because all those
people hate me
which is really fun have you found that
as you ascend um
to uh the next echelon of success you've
got negativity
oh i feel like i'm getting like a lot of
weird positivity that i don't know what
to do with it's
like passive aggressive or is it real uh
both like i just can't i i can't tell
if people like me and for what reason
interesting
like i don't know if you like me because
i have more followers now i don't know
if you like it because you're friends
whitney anyone fans or so you're in a
place where now you feel
i'm just obsessed with anyone listening
to this podcast i think wants to
um achieve and ascend and
and that's a mistake i think it's really
important to manage expectations of
when you get everything you want which i
think the people that listen to this
podcast
will uh if you listen closely to auntie
whitney
uh that it's it's not gonna solve all
your problems it's gonna just be a new
set of problems it's just gonna be a
different set of problems
um and i was definitely
um shocked when i got what is
whatever success means ostensibly
successful and then all of a sudden
everyone was mad at me yeah or
they were nice to me for the wrong
reasons right and i was suspicious
and i was like oh god i just did this
because i wanted people to love me and
like me and now
everyone either loves me and likes me
for the wrong reasons or doesn't like me
this totally backfired that was my first
impulse
yeah and i will say so grateful for
everything what i love about
having benton on tour with us is when
we're bitching and complaining benton is
like
literally so many people would love to
be where you are and you need to
remember that
and it's so incredibly healthy and
helpful to have that and also from
someone who's like so funny
and grateful and appreciative every day
like spent is just the best
and anytime i complain benton's like oh
great want to trade right
and you're like got it thank you and i
have friends like that keeps me so
humble
yeah my my friends are like that too
where they're like oh i'm sorry
is it hard like doing a show with
whitney yeah and you don't know if a
couple girls like you like shut the fuck
up like yeah
it's it is true and if you weren't if
you weren't doing a show with me or if
you weren't successful they'd not like
you for another reason oh they already
didn't like me like it's so stupid but
yeah i mean i literally asked you in
denver i was like is this person
uh following me or messaging me or
something because they want to sleep
with you
because with me i have a male comedian
messaged
taylor and this is but this is about you
i think it's really important like
i was um on a bike ride this morning uh
thinking about what i wanted to talk to
you about and one of the main
things was how we fill in the blanks
is our business how we fill in the
blanks
is ours so
someone dm'd you everything's a worse
shock test a project we're projection
machines right
right so you got a dm from someone and
then you made up a story you wrote the
subtext which was that someone said
flirted with taylor and she decided that
the flirt was to try to get to me
even though this guy has my phone number
and email and could flirt with me direct
and my
instagram could flirt with me directly
at any moment right this is what i like
to call bad science this is just bad
science but
bad science is intimidating and i'm not
yeah but i've known this person for 15
years i know but still if we were going
to fuck we would have fucked by now
i know i just but so but but but it's
important there's no take the judgment
out of it
you showed up to that exchange with a
people are using me to get to someone
else why wouldn't they want
you i mean the younger
cuter not true version i am younger with
bangs
i mean you hate them so no i like your
bangs we just need to work on how to
style them are you serious
well yeah they look are you being
serious right now well right now they
they look a little have you seen the um
don't do this
don't i'm just telling you right now
don't do it
don't do it okay i know what you're
doing you're doing it for content
you don't even feel this way i'm not
you're doing this for content whitney
does a thing
where she just says fucked up shit
because it's funny
and then we talk later and you're like
oh no i actually really like it and i'm
like well why would you say that
publicly
like no i've done i've gone to couples
therapy with a sociopath i
know what you're doing business it's
called business it's called being a
mogul try it you've never pitched a show
with whitney cummings and you wish you
could this is what it's like
you get on the zoom call and then she
proceeds to make fun of your
hair face body and if she can't find
anything there she will make fun of the
art in your apartment
she will find a way to demean you in
front of every
television executive that is
that you will be working for and
pitching to for years and finds a way
to say something that cuts you down but
then 10 minutes later is like
taylor is the voice of her generation
and you have to come out of it feeling
very like weird and stockholm syndrome-y
and you know what at first it really
affected me and now i just go nope
that's yours
i know what's happening and that's you
and the fucked up thing is
i have learned how to stand up to you
from you
isn't that fucked up you're welcome you
are i mean you're my new dad
i'm kind of emotional
i do think a lot of what i'm doing is
testing you and trying to make you
tougher
right and i'm fine so that you can
handle me
right i'm training you to fight me yes
and eventually i'm
training you this is like what is it
when han solo got killed by his own son
i feel like what is it is that is that
how it goes it's spoiler alert
yeah i feel like i'm training you to
eventually
uh exterminate murder yeah you want out
i'm training you to fight me at some
point right you've told me that you're
like i want us to get so successful i
want us to have a falling out over money
or something stupid like oh that'd be my
dream
it's so weird that you want that and i'm
just here like trying to form lasting
relationships that enrich and fulfill my
life how's that going and i mean besides
this pretty well
i mean i have left your home very
emotionally
texting all of my friends that i've had
for a long time going like i'm so glad
we're friends
because it is exhausting sometimes being
in this coven
you've built yeah where i'm just like
there's a lot going on here
yeah and like everyone here is great and
talented and cool but i am not i feel
very disconnected
in this space i'm not like a group
person yeah
i was like that yeah i'm very much like
a one or two people at a time
type of person and what do you think
that is i think it's just my personality
i think i'm kind of introverted
and like and i think it's important to
uh explain what introverted means
because i got the definition wrong for a
very long time
introverted is not is that you derive
energy from being alone and extroverted
as you derive
energy from being with other people
right so i used to think i was
extroverted because i was like i do
stand up and i'm like loud and i talk a
lot but that doesn't mean it's not
depleting me
after i do a podcast after i do stand up
you see me on the road like i
i can't talk for the whole rest of the
night yeah you know like i don't talk
all day to anybody
and then i go to stand up at eight
o'clock and i'm like and i wanna
whereas extroverts like one of my best
friends dory
she has dinner plans every night she'll
do a drinks
a dinner a zoom she's like she'll bring
her
i would be exhausted she derives and it
energizes her it fuels her
and right so i think it's it's not your
personal preference like i like being
alone it's just
how you derive energy i think it's
important to delineate those when
when so that you're not over
pathologizing yourself oh completely i
don't think i dislike being with people
i think it's just
again it's draining me as opposed to
filling me up yes
so when i enter a room it's like i
started a road trip
where i'm like well i'm getting less and
less gas yeah and at a certain point i'm
going to have
to find a gas station and i can't wait
till i'm on empty
otherwise shit's going to get dicey like
when you're around a lot of people it
it's exhausting because you have to
shape shift for each person
i ask that because that's how i used to
be it was like this person like
i would be exhausted in a group of
people
before a couple years ago because
i was like well i have to be small for
this person i have to be big for this
person i have to give advice to this
person i have to be funny for this
person i
could not be funny for this person so it
was like i felt like i was constantly
just like shape-shifting shape-shifting
right and that was exhausting i don't
think i do that i don't think i shape
i don't either i think i'm pretty much
the same all the time i think what
shifts is however people
interpret my personality or something
like you have a little bit of uh
do you think it exhausts you like
wondering if you're
doing well with the person or you're
worried the person doesn't like you or
your word your presence is triggering to
them because you got successful recently
i feel like there's a little of that
there's a little bit of that last one
like you don't want to i want to make
people comfortable
if i feel any like weirdness yeah
someone even if they don't think there
is or they think it's just on their end
like
i'm very direct i'm very like open i'm
just like
i just need to say this and it's not a
thing but i just gotta like
get this out here like and if i can't do
that with somebody like i
i've known whatever female comics female
actors
male comics male actor where i'm just
like oh
you're never going to be direct with me
yeah and that's
fine but i just don't interact with
those people yeah because it's a waste
of time but it's also yeah that's right
and also
coming to someone with a hey let me be
direct with you that doesn't mean
they're capable
of receiving it and that doesn't mean
they're capable of being direct back
right to a lot of people that is
interpreted as an attack or a criticism
and their defenses
come up yeah and then you're just in
trauma response mode and it's like
pointless
right you know what i mean they're
triggered and they're just like you know
ego is running the show but sometimes
people are great and sometimes people
are like oh i don't want any weirdness
either and i'm glad we're friends like
a lot of times it goes great yeah and
people appreciate it you know what's
interesting about you
what if you bring up my bangs again i
swear to fucking god whitney
feels like a goddamn trap no what is it
no i mean i just was thinking about you
this morning and i just was like
what if the worst that's happened to you
has happened
that would be so great it probably has
what if nothing's wrong
that's something we say an allen on
where we go what if nothing's wrong
then what then what i mean what if just
for today nothing's wrong
what would you do i don't know what
would happen would you be okay
could you handle being out of the woods
do you keep planting trees to make sure
the woods stay
you stay in the woods i don't think i'm
planting trees and start planting trees
i don't think i'm planting trees i think
i'm just looking at the soil real hard
like if there's a tree coming i'm gonna
fuck it so you have a
the uh shoe is gonna drop all the time
all the time what if it dropped already
um
i mean a lot of shoes have dropped and
sometimes i was like look i was right
and sometimes i'm like didn't even see
that coming uh-huh
gotta gotta be even more of a swivel
because i think the main thing i have
with you is like
i have to give you the dignity of your
own experience and let you
learn on your own but there's other
times where i'm like ugh i
just my biggest regret about
my 20s is that i didn't enjoy it because
i was so
busy worrying about things going wrong
yeah and i didn't realize that
everything that had gone wrong already
went wrong right and that now things
were actually going right but i couldn't
tell the difference
when things started going right all i
did was anticipate
the damocles sword falling so i couldn't
enjoy it and i know
i hate it when people say just enjoy it
just have fun like easier said than done
like i have
you know you have 26 years of neural
pathways that have been crystallized
because something
you know your mom died when you were
young like of course the worst thing's
always gonna happen
like that is such a major trauma
on the brain but i just
wish that i had earlier in my life
not wasted so much time
expecting things to go wrong that is
definitely what i've been
working on the most this year and i
think the pandemic honestly really
helped me with that because i was like
oh everything can go away yeah and it's
happened yeah
and is there something liberating about
everything going wrong fully i
know nothing's gonna go wrong yeah after
my dad died a couple years ago there was
something
obviously it broke my heart uh but i
think it kind of broke my heart
is my friend nikki uh from college you
met nikki yeah sad she goes
you know if you're going to have your
heart broken
make sure it breaks open and when my dad
died there was sort of like a well
that's so beautiful
i know oh my god i know
shout out to nikki wow the best just
make sure it breaks open
don't let it broke break inside yeah and
after my dad i was like well that's done
what's the worst come at me bro
like there's a come at me yeah thing i'm
referencing a meme because i'm young and
i wear hats it's really good that come
at me bro
it's like an anteater that's like come
at me bro or maybe it's a panda on a
swing i don't know
now i'm just doing my act um and uh
there's
there's a i just wish you had more of a
come at me mentality i'm just like
the shoes dropped like what like i just
want you to go down the slide
oh totally you know the roller coasters
they go tick tick tick tick tick and
you're going up up up up up up up up up
like i feel like you're always going up
up up up up up up up like when you get
to go down when do you get to go wee
right oh i i really do kind of feel like
that very recently yeah
that shirt is is i mean this is your
this i do look like i work in a water
park that's right maybe
i'm going down the slide that's what it
looks like it looks like i got a summer
job
at a water park exactly what it is and
i'm like just on my phone like all right
go
go you look that looks like a shirt that
in an 80s sitcom
that a racist costume designer would
give to the waiter at a mexican
restaurant
i mean i really i like it
i think it's fun i like that it has
every color in it like you could have a
crazy nail color i don't right now but
it would like still look like it went
together i am
super into this for you because i i feel
like you self-deprive and we'll talk
about that in a minute
yeah and you do you self-deprive a
little bit and you don't celebrate
enough with your
um clothes and life and choices
oh my goodness so we've been talking to
taylor tomlinson this episode
about self-care mental health
you cannot have mental health unless you
have physical health menton
well someone should tell me someone
should let my body know i just told you
um daily harvest yeah that is
listen if i i don't don't even say
anything i'm just gonna hold this up
i'm holding it up for those of you not
list not watching i'm holding up a daily
harvest
what more do you need to know they've
nailed it dude
they nailed it it's everything healthy
in a carton that's pre-done super cute
simple pack i'm a sucker for like
elegant me too cute packaging
it's not like embarrassing or like just
doesn't look just like trash it just
makes me feel like such an adult
yeah if i want to feel like a glowing
icon i grab one of these from the
freezer
everything healthy you need in here and
it's done
i'm on the go i feel like a mom picking
up her kids after yoga
i just am like it makes me feel like
an adult with their shit together it
makes it very easy to be healthy for
sure it also just like checks
all the body it's like fast it's simple
it's easy it's healthy it's organic
and i feel like um
i don't know i just i feel less crazy
when i eat these i feel like i'm not a
mess you know sometimes like you eat
you're like oh god did i just eat like a
bar in the car
and you're hungry and you don't know if
you're hungry or not and then you have
low blood sugar and then it fucks up
your whole day
you don't get to eat unhealthy that
is rude to the people around you i'm
just saying if you're not eating well
it's a disservice to the people around
you because they have to deal with your
moods and your low blood sugar
and your bad health and you're
complaining and you're bad sleep like
you don't get to not eat well
you have no excuse the only excuse you
had before daily harvest was well it's
hard and it's complicated and who has
time to go to the farmer's market and
get all the fruit
fair until now daily harvest
no excuses yeah you should be hangry you
have no excuses to be hangry you show up
with one of those a little straw in it
it's a little hole for a straw on the
top
that's so good no that's on this one
this is the smoothie so this is the
daily harvest smoothie
with a cacao and avocado yeah
i'm that guy now and it's delicious you
can show up with one of those people
know you're ready to work look at this
and then you just blend it up and then
there's a hole for the straw it's like
what haven't they thought of these
people
daily harvest and then sorry this one is
the oat bowl with mulberry
and dragon fruit i'm never going to buy
a dragon fruit on my own i don't know
how to cut a dragon fruit i don't know
what to do with that i'm not
the girl from game of thrones i don't
know how to tame a dragon
fruit okay but if you have one of those
people like what are you drinking you're
like dragon fruit
dragon fruit and mulberry i guess i'm
just better than you maybe you're not
ready for the meeting today but i'm
having dragons dude you bring this to
work and your co-workers are like damn
that bitch oats raspberry
blueberry dragon fruit and mulberry you
just fill it with a cup of milk
uh all the uh three-fourths of the way
up to the top
and then you can like soak it overnight
in the fridge you can eat it right there
you can heat it it's up to you it's your
world and if you're someone who likes
like to chew food
they don't just have smoothies they have
crisp flatbreads
yes there's a lot of salt foods they
have soups which
oh yeah yeah we're fans of soups yeah
the broccoli there's a broccoli soup
that is like to die for
i mean everything they make is so good
and so easy you can bring
and you bring them to um work i guess
people are working
remotely uh a lot now but you bring them
you put them in the fridge
that's it i've been bringing them on
planes recently because we've been
traveling so much yeah you don't bring
anything on a plane so that i
so that i don't eat trash in the airport
just bring this so that you're not stuck
eating some garbage and then you're
dehydrated and
you're a mess and not fun to be around
um
also it's just guilt-free on so many
levels there's no preservative no added
sugars no artificial ingredients
no chocolate and they've only thought of
it all you just keep them in your
freezer i mean if you hate yourself
don't get it
that is a yeah that's a good if you hate
yourself don't buy this product
it won't match your brand if you like
yourself by it if you want to continue
being sick and unhealthy uh and
malnourished
do not buy this product by all means
daily harvest is not for you
such an impressive ad
daily harvest makes it easy to eat clean
undeniably delicious food no matter what
your day brings keep it simple
with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com enter promo code good
for you to get 25
off your first box that's promo code
good for you 25
off that's like a couple of these off
your first box at dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com really quick don't cut
this out leslie grossman is who taught
me about daily harvest before we even
had a podcast
daily uh uh leslie grossman who was like
super busy mom friend of mine one of the
smartest people i know she's in a lot of
ryan murphy's shows she was on
the show popular she put this on her
instagram and made one and i was like
what is that
so just fyi just true story about why
this is really a product i use
speaking of products i use are we just
gonna keep rolling through
let's just keep rolling through i this
is not a joke
this is not a joke i'm fully oh sorry
mona
wearing me undies
those pants are tight huh would you not
focus on that
i'm wearing me undies
now what i mean i'm always wearing my
knees who's realer than me
doing an ad for me undies already
wearing them
i mean it's hard not to wear them when
they're delivered to your house every
month
isn't it i'm just saying i have a whole
basket of underwear
in where i'm staying in my attic and i
see all my underwear and i
dig around for the me undies i mean i
only have mandy's at this point i've had
minnie so
see i still have some of my old
underwear and your old underwear your
ratchet ass old underwear that looks
like little nasty crusty dental floss
next to the me undies you're like oh get
them out of here get rid of all them
because i literally i've had a
manuscript now for three years
oh that's see i have so many underwear i
only have like
seven me undies and i portion or what's
the word i like parse them out to be
like
okay i'm gonna wear these tomorrow and
i'm gonna wear these on the plane and i
have something important on friday i
gotta
like i'll i'll ration my me undies
because i know they put me in a better
mood
like today i almost put on this old like
sketchy pair of underwear i had and i
was like this is a big day i need my me
undies yeah and there's different styles
i didn't even know we were reading a
miandi's ad today
there's different styles too so you can
really you know pick and choose what you
kind of what mood you're in there's boy
shorts and thongs and
full coverage and all that and they also
make socks which i don't know if you've
ever tried the socks
but the socks are legit the best sock
i've ever worn
it's the only thong that doesn't feel
like it's sawing you in half
because they're made of the softest
material they're like it's like
hugging your butthole you're made of
mother nature hugging
your taint the only mother who should be
touching your privacy
your crevices so gentle
like a like a um it's like hummingbirds
pulled them on you isn't it
like like a considerate lover
your your me undies just glide onto your
nether regions
lovingly sensitively and
bring you to climax emotional climax
i think your mandy's might be a little
different do yours vibrate because i
don't do that
the undies they're my favorite underwear
if you guys haven't tried them they're
the best underwear
honestly like it's a game changer what
the underwear you're where it starts off
your day
my day is totally decided by how
comfortable
they have halloween ones out now too i
don't have any which ones
there i mean there's a whole bunch of
different options oh that's funny to
wear bones i think on something i want
one
i want one that has a little ghost on it
so when i'm hooking up with the guy they
just know
that you're gonna leave i'm yeah i'm
about to disappear
or that you're dead inside about to
ghost you but it'd be so much easier you
put the caution tape
there's a little ghost in my uterus yeah
you should have those those ghosts
underwear because it'd be so much easier
than you always riding caution dead
inside above your vagina
me undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15
off and free shipping no-brainer
especially because they have 100
satisfaction guarantee to get your 15
off your first pair free shipping and
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
whitney meundies.com
whitney another thing i've learned from
you your hair's pink and
at first i think i was like what are you
doing yeah is she okay i'm like it looks
good but
i attached my wagon to the wrong star
and honestly every time i was like maybe
you died back for this one event and you
were like
fuck you it's good and i'm like it
actually is good like it can be both
that's why
i'm like don't go there like yeah you
know this is good
so again i've learned a lot from that i
i see you s
like enjoying your life in a way that i
don't think you have before this and
i've only
met you since you started doing it yep
and i i just thought you've been like
this for a while and so it's taken i was
like i know it's taken me a while to go
oh whitney's like enjoying being
successful for the first time
and i just met her at that moment and i
thought you've been like this for a long
time so it's great for me because i'm
benefiting from your experience
yes which is like someone has to so
valuable
but the the come at me bro mentality
i've definitely felt like that in the
last year because like
what did you do what are you gonna do
hurt me yeah like that's my thing
what is the worst that can happen it's
like you know and we'll talk about you
know dating and relationships in a
second but it's just sort of like
what are you gonna do like that's my
thing what are you gonna break my heart
it's broken right what are you gonna
hurt me i'm hurt you're going to wound
me i'm fucking wounded
like yeah bring it yeah like i think and
there's a um for those of you that that
are
sort of resonating with this mentality
or feel it all like connected to this
there's um the tools fill studs and
barry
i can't remember his last name uh phil
stutz who um
amazing like psychotherapist super
famous he had a great episode of marin
um that we've referenced on the show
before they wrote a book called the
tools it's a little bit corny
it's a little bit am like if you listen
to this podcast you're probably way more
advanced
than some parts of the book but there
it's all these like mental tools on how
to
have perspective and gratitude and live
more in the present like one of them is
the deathbed exercise where you imagine
yourself on your deathbed and like what
choices you would make if you were on
your deathbed yeah and one of them is
called the reversal of desire where you
actively crave the very thing that you
fear
so that you just get it and visualize
moving through it right so you just it's
interesting i mean it's it
after i read it i found myself doing the
exercises i mean it
seems lame because you're basically like
i want to be cheated on
like you have to like say it out loud
and like yell it and and
crave it and it's a really powerful
exercise because it makes you realize
like
if the worst thing that could happen to
me happen like i'd still be okay
oh yeah and that the fear of the thing
happening is so much worse than the
thing happening
yes so i remember like when i i had a
situation where
i was in a bad relationship shocker
of the day and or no whatever
it was it was it wasn't bad at the time
you don't know it's bad when you're in
it necessarily it was what it was and i
got so many gifts from it i like to call
my
bad exes santa claus because they just
gave me so many gifts
and you worship them blindly and they
only came once a year yeah
um and
and they had a wife
and they live with children and they
work for them
[Laughter]
i remember talking to my therapist
georgia who i um
you guys know and she was like let's
just walk through the worst case
scenario
because it's like he's gonna leave me
i'm gonna leave it whatever and we just
walk through it and you like visualize
yourself going through
the thing you're so scared of you're
like yeah i'd be fine if that happened
yeah that's the weird thing
it's the amorphous vague fear
of what could happen as soon as you get
specific going okay the worst thing that
could possibly happen
to you is right now
what i get kidnapped and held in a
basement for 22 years and have to
have my captors babies do you have your
phone can you
live stream it or no oh that's pretty
bad
so you can oh don't play this fucking
game without wi-fi this isn't gonna work
out this will not
sell the tools book i can think of the
worst thing
there's no wi-fi in the case the worst
thing is that happens to one of my
family members and we never find them
and i never know what happened to them
look
the the vow is doing very well on hbo
max
is that what happens in the valley do we
get to make a documentary at the end
if it'll work out for someone else yeah
if you want to think of it that way
if you want to be all christian about it
and be like it's part of god's plan your
biggest fear is that you will get
kidnapped
no i have a lot of big my biggest fear
is that something will happen to one of
my sisters that's
one of my biggest fears and because your
mom died so young that
in your hippocampus and like that makes
sense that tracks yes
yes yes yes but think about the pro this
is where i go with that
when my uh after my
my mom and my dad had strokes the same
year which is like pretty the
probability of that happening is pretty
low yeah that's
so to me i just i just get into math i
just go like your mom died when you were
eight like
what are the chances your sisters are
also gonna you know what i mean this is
like who do you think you are that
you're gonna be
the outlier then i just go like
oh my god maybe my fear
that i got honestly has transmuted into
me thinking i'm
constitutionally like special like am i
gonna be the one
that likes whose mom died today and then
whose sister died
i feel the opposite way i feel like i'm
not i know that i'm not special and
life is random and i grew up thinking
that it wasn't
like what are the mathematical chances i
i like to just go to math because
feelings are not math feelings aren't
facts they're not they're bad feelings
are just
bad math yeah horrible math
and so for me i'm just like it feels
like my sister could die at some point
right why wouldn't it my brain is
designed to protect me
and given what's happened to me that
makes perfect sense to my monkey brain
my monkey mind but like mathematically
what are the chances
yeah you go this could happen yeah it
makes sense that i'm worried about it
uh-huh
but worrying about it is isn't going to
help anything and in fact it's going to
make you
sick right and age you right faster
yeah and i just i find
and maybe this isn't for you walking
through something like that yeah
helps me because i just go like yeah i'd
be okay but
let's do like more fun fears like you
know like one of my biggest fears was
that i would like
fall in love with somebody and i would
be wrong about them and
like lose who i thought was the love of
my life and like that happened to me
a year ago yeah and i am so grateful now
i was grateful like two months after
that i knew who that person was and it
i didn't marry them and all these things
and
that was my worst possible fear and it
gave me such a
come at me bro mentality going into my
next relationship where i was kind of
like
you know if something horrible happened
which it didn't but i was like if
something horrible happened
i could handle it because i just did the
worst hardest thing
and the thing i was most afraid of and
the most like obsessively trying not to
make happen like
i was so i was trying to be so perfect
in that relationship
every day all the time and when it fell
apart i was like
oh i like made it about me i was like
well this is my fault i could have been
doing more and i'm like you literally
couldn't have given any more blow jobs
but like
i just no i
i just maybe that's what would fix my
salivary gland
i mean i have a blocked salivary gland
and i need to produce more saliva
no i'm i have a house i'm not easy
i give i give blow jobs with my vagina
oh you're very efficient businesswoman
um
but yeah that was like my biggest fear
is that i was gonna find
who i thought was like my soul mate and
then i would lose them
because i was wrong and it happened and
i was like oh and then two months later
i was
dating somebody great who i connected
with really deeply
and like you know had more experiences
that i wouldn't have had otherwise and
like
my special turned out better and i
worked on myself more and like
you know there's just yeah but the more
shit you go through the more evidence
you have to point to that like
i'm gonna be fine if more fucked up shit
happens to me
but it's also the same way it's like the
harder you train in the gym
the better your butt's gonna look right
the harder your relationships are
obsessed with my butt
i am obsessed with your butt the it's
like
it's like on it's like we should call hr
the my hr department in my house
i should have it frankly um i'm just
saying it's like
you know what really helped me on my
journey
was that comparing
working out in the gym exercising and
how your
it changes your body with the work you
do on your brain and how it changes your
brain yeah you know so it's like
if you are going hard in relationships
and practicing relationships it's all
practice dates are all
it's all proud just look at it as
practice look at it as training
the harder you train the better your
body the stronger your body's gonna be
the harder you training relationships
the stronger your mind is gonna be and
the more evidence you're gonna have and
the more proof and the better you're
gonna get to know yourself like
you cannot look at relationships as
failures um
it's all just practice yeah yeah it's
just practice i'm not religious anymore
but one thing that
they did say like i don't know if it was
youth group or church or something at
one point
was uh when you pray for patience
god doesn't give you patience he gives
you opportunities to be patient
interesting which i think is basically
what you just said which is just you
have to treat everything
as practice like you can't get better at
being in a relationship without being in
a relationship that's right
but you also need to practice calling it
when you call it
so i think for me i was thinking about
um
you because i had this situation
recently you've seen me dating yeah
you've seen
it's wild
a lot for someone who has read so many
books
holy shit what have you learned what
have you
got what have you gleaned i have seen
you in two
very i've only seen you in two different
things yeah and it has been
polar opposite polar opposite so we're
which is interesting because i think i
think i think we should talk about this
really can we i mean i don't want to get
into too specific but you talk about i
don't care i mean at this point
i mean we can edit it at this point
trust me i i
last night was thinking about this and i
got emotional and i'll probably get
emotional if i think about it now
which is that sharing my personal life
my private life like
writing a book about having eating
disorders and like all the stuff
i recently shared something on a podcast
about love addiction and my experience
with it and
i believe it might have made something
weird with someone i'm dating
because they don't know what the
definition means or whatever
and or not it might have made something
weird
it might not have there was a little bit
of a weird reaction to it
and i had this fear that was like oh my
god do i
over share and
is this going to me doing this podcast
and sharing all these intimate details
about my life which i do because i want
to be able to be of service to people
and i want to be able to
be the person that i wish i had when i
was younger like i wish
i just am trying to make the podcast
that i wish was available when i was
20 and trying to figure shit out and um
and am i doing this at the expense of my
own personal life
right maybe yeah on the other hand
you're trying to destroy our friendship
which is supposedly very important to
you
uh you mean business partnership great
friendship sorry
what's the difference i am obsessed with
you i really do love you um
and then i vacillate and i go well
if this scares this person off then you
i don't fuck with you don't fuck with me
i'm fine
like if if this scares you off bye dude
um you know because i am always torn and
i think
anyone at any level of social media
whether you have 10 followers or 10
million followers like
we should be careful with what we share
yeah
for professional reasons and personal
reasons and be
careful and take care of ourselves and
protect ourselves restraint of pen and
tongue is a form of self-care
not everyone needs to know everything
all the time it gives sick people
just weapons to hurt you later or it can
just expose someone to your
vulnerabilities too soon or
you can trauma bond with somebody that's
sort of a thing i want to talk about
with you
i i truly believe i wish i'd known this
in my 20s that when you're dating
someone
start dating someone do not share too
much too soon about your traumas about
your
alcoholic dad about your breakups just
like save it
save it like no but i have a podcast so
right if you're i say that to you guys
do as i
say not as i do yeah and i'm because
otherwise
you're gonna trauma bond with that
person and you're gonna get a false
sense of intimacy
if on the first date you're like and my
sister's in jail and my
i had this assault in my life it's like
it's too much information too quick
yep and the person is gonna maybe pity
you or feel sorry for you
and then they're and then you're always
gonna wonder are you just with me
because you feel bad for me you're
getting
a false sense of intimacy it's just it's
not appropriate
it's too much too soon um
or you're just giving people too much of
yourself before they've earned it that's
right
now that they pity you but they're like
oh my gosh this person feels so close to
me and it's like no no i'm trying to
feel close to you because i
desperately want to feel close to
someone and you don't want to feel
too close to someone too soon because
then after a first date they
they're probably still dating other
people right you don't know what the
fuck's going on you don't know who
they're following you don't know who's
commenting on their shit
and then you're setting yourself up to
be victimized later because then you've
shared all this stuff two days later you
see that some girls comment on his
poster like but i shared all this stuff
but they have so much of me that was
your fault you shouldn't have shared all
that
yeah they didn't ask for that hold it
yes and you know have restraint
of pen and tongue and do not overshare
like that is something that i wish i
knew
younger but uh
i'm really being circuitous to get to
this
so you've seen me in two different
things
i'm over sharing and if the person hears
this
fuck it um which one i'm fine being
alone honestly like we know
don't get defensive just share you don't
have to go and i'll be
fine we know house
you're fine i have pink hair i have hats
you're doing great
like everyone knows that i just i'm like
a little bit at a point in my life and i
and i don't know if it's something that
you should learn from or the people
listening could learn from which is just
like
i don't know if i've already exposed too
much of myself
right i might have that shit might have
sailed
you know because i i personally just
like i don't want to have secrets that's
part of why i started a podcast like and
part of why the podcast
is what it is like i just personally
don't want to have secrets from anyone
yeah um and i found myself feeling a
little bit ashamed of the thing that i
shared on social media the other day
that this person kind of had a
weird reaction to and i was like you
know what i i
i you're in or you're out did you share
that you
had been a love addict addiction
love addiction is like i think something
that's really misunderstood love
addiction
uh i think a lot of people think it's
just like they're in love all the time
that's
that's not true love addiction is
essentially
when you're in relationships you can't
get out of you can't extricate yourself
from them because it's become
addictive in some way so it doesn't mean
like you're constantly
in love most love addicts whatever
they're doing is not love
it's chemical addiction you're
recreating your childhood circumstances
and you're stuck in something so um the
way that i like to define addiction
is uh you know when your life becomes
unmanageable
and when you when something
stops being fun so that's when something
becomes an addiction right so when
someone's like drinking
a marriage it becomes an obligation
instead of his fun so the whole point of
heroin and cocaine is supposed to be fun
but then you're addicted to it when it's
like you're just doing it because you
have to
to check this neurochemical box and it's
not even fun anymore
right that's an addiction when it
becomes an obligation you're not even
getting those dopamine hits you're just
serving your tolerance yeah so and
you can't it stops being a choice stops
being a choice
so if i choose to have rose on a sunday
i'm a normie if i have to have that rose
at two o'clock or else i'm gonna get a
headache and i'm gonna be angry and
you know i'm gonna start yelling at
people that's when it's an addiction
right so for me if i can't choose to
leave a relationship at any point
that's bad for me that's not serving me
that's hurting me
that's when it's an addiction right
because i don't i can't leave
so i've been in relationships where i'm
like
i feel stuck because of my codependents
i feel like their hooks are in me
if i leave they're going to fall apart
they can't live without me
they need me this is all these are
addictive thoughts
they need me i'm going to hurt them
they're going to kill themselves
whatever
that nonsense um
i don't i i'll i'll be alone or i'll
yeah
i'm too old yeah this ship has i might
as well just stay
all fall apart i'll fall apart or like
you start doing the math of like i
remember in
when i was dating santa claus um i would
i was like well i'm 32 and like by the
time i meet someone else
it's me two years and then i'll have a
baby like you start doing that timeline
shit right which is the socially
constructed shit and biology biology
sexist
so when you start rationalizing
minimizing justifying why you should
stay in something that has nothing to do
with
wanting to be in it and feeling good
right
so that's what that's an addict that's
love addiction it doesn't mean you just
fall in love with everyone that you see
on the street that's not what love
addiction is
but you are always looking for that and
trying to create that
with people a toxic relationship yeah
right
no isn't that being a love addict
because you can be in a relationship
like that and be addicted to a
relationship and not be a love addict i
feel like love addicts have a pattern of
doing that over and over and over again
because they're so scared of being alone
and like if i'm alone i'm worthless i'm
gonna fall apart i was single for two
i didn't date for two years like
interesting yeah you can
it's when you're in the relationship
what happens it's not that you're always
in one so it's like
um being an alcoholic when you're not
drinking you're
i guess still an alcoholic but you're
not an act of addiction it's when you're
when you start to drink that's when it
becomes a problem
so for me it's like i after
i took like two years off of dating and
sex and everything like i just like took
a break
and i was like i want to date you i want
to date you like i was like super cool
being on my own it's once you enter
into the dance and the neurochemicals
start firing
and your childhood circumstances start
being
recreated that your inner child comes
out and then you kind of are just like
in the ring and can't get out right we
say it's like it's like being on the
dance floor like you're on the dance
floor and you just can't get off the
dance floor
but that's like anything that's like
being addicted to caffeine or sugar if
you take
you know a year off of caffeine yes
you're like i'm great i don't need it
but then as soon as you start becoming
dependent on it again you're like oh
this is you have to just know that's a
problem once you're in it you don't see
the way out either like
you see someone that's in a relationship
that's like so clearly bad but
they don't see it there's just no doors
yeah it's just no doors
that's all it's like i'm in the ring
with you and i just forgot that i
i don't know how to just walk away it's
right when someone's in active addiction
with
any kind of chemical which is why it's
taken me so long to have patience with
it because you're like
why did you stop drinking it seems so
obvious
because i don't get chemical
dependencies like i just seem so obvious
to me like well if you can't
if drinking is a problem just stop
drinking right love is a chemical love
isn't it
so you have a chemical we call it the
internal drug cabinet
yeah so the dopamine i know the internal
drug cabinet so like
are you using so there have been times
that i've been in relationships i'm like
oh i'm just on drugs
oh yeah oxytocin and all these and we
talked about it
i've talked about this on the podcast a
lot but like no
if this person is a drug dealer are you
with a drug dealer or not
yeah and for me a lot of my bad
relationships is like oh you're just
like a drug dealer
and i'm chemically dependent on you
which is part of the reason that
now i don't sleep with someone
my new rule is like 12 dates
about right so if she sleeps with you
before that doesn't really like you that
much
no so i don't see myself getting
chemically dependent on you
yeah too short the two things i've seen
you in are one that was very casual for
you
and possibly not for the other person
and that was hard to watch
i felt really bad for the person it's
this it's i think and the other
and then the other uh which is more
recent
which is the first time i've ever seen
you impressed by
literally anyone literally anyone you're
like oh
everyone listening is like but she's
impressed by people who come on her
podcast she's not the first time and you
almost fucked it up
i watched you almost fuck it up because
you were just like i don't know like you
started doing all the things i do
yeah that you were just chastising me
for which is like
this person might just be using me this
person you know
is not responding in the way i want this
person isn't as
invested or doesn't get it or doesn't
see me filling in the blanks filling in
the blanks before this person even at a
chance and this person's being so direct
with you
and like i'm on facetime with you
watching you freak out in a way i've
never seen you
freak out well here's what you saw which
was adorable that i think is really
important
you saw my inner you you met my inner
child
yes and um because you're used to
unhealthy people
like all of your feelings are so valid
because of what you've been surrounded
by
you actually know what someone kicks up
in you yeah so it's like
if you know i am my attachment strategy
which
you guys know google it as you're
listening like you know i
get anxious preoccupied if someone
is not anxious preoccupied with me so if
someone is anxious preoccupied with me
and needs my validation needs my
attention i get dismissive
yeah a more layman's way to put it is
like if someone likes me too much i just
get
i feel secure and then i kind of get
bored right it's like
i i got you so i don't need to chase you
or wonder about you i'm not saying any
of this is good this is just the way
that i'm wired
but if somebody if i project
that someone is not available
it kicks up my dad shit
which is like i have to work for your
approval i have
and i don't like saying daddy issues
people have to stop saying that it's
just
it's too vague it's it's dismissive it's
pejorative i don't like it it's really
ruining the word daddy it really
it makes it less sexy and bad to say
you totally ruined that word that's why
i don't call babies babies
i call them infants because i want to
say baby
because you want to say baby in bed yeah
i mean babies have ruined the ability
to sexualize babies yeah it's like
fucking stop you guys like now i'm a
pedophile
fuck because i just want the guy i'm
fucking to be a baby
no i can't say that not to say daddy
um but i think it's important to just
know like what comes up in you and
and uh when i get i mean i
the word triggered i love annie
letterman does this joke about um how
since we're all like just giant
five-year-olds
when she says triggered she says twig
the way a kid would say i know it's just
like a good so i'm just like i'm
twinkled
like say it like that just to remind
yourself that your inner child is
actually what's freaking out not your
adult self but
when there is an absence of
communication or what i perceive as an
absence of communication if someone like
kicks up that familiarity right we like
pattern recognition like oh i know this
pattern
which is i don't hear from someone
constantly because they're not an addict
and they're not smothering me and
they're not constantly available
i go into inner child mode and
sadness comes up i have so i have such a
fucking deep well of sadness that when
someone triggers the feelings
that i felt when i was a kid yeah
whether they want it has nothing to do
with them
they didn't cause it not their if i'm
crying it has nothing to do with you
dude like nothing but like you were on
the phone with me or we were facetiming
or something and
i was texting with this person and
he like something about like not being
available the day that i thought they
were going to be available and i just
started
bawling crying for like an hour it just
it like
twiggled a deep well of sadness yeah
that had nothing to do with them and i i
really like to use the word unresolved i
was like this person is helping me
process some unresolved shit right
yeah yeah all right
uh this episode we've been talking a lot
about
how to improve yourself how to not go to
the problem for the solution
how to not go to your relationship or
your business um
problem or family problem um
and we'll keep talking about it till we
figure out how to stop doing it i'm just
saying don't go to the problem for the
solution that's a big theme
on this podcast but better help
is a place you can go that is a way
better place to go
than your problem if i have an issue
with you benton i don't go to you
never which would never happen i would
go to better help
first talk it through with a licensed
professional
and they would say we love benton we
don't understand yeah exactly and then i
haven't ruined our relationship by being
like i'm mad at you they'll go whitney
you're fucking crazy
benton's the best imagine if that was
the response that better help gave
people i mean
any any licensed professional would say
give that advice
within under 48 hours you can start
communicating it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online so for
those of you that are like i want to get
better
i've read a lot of books um i want to
improve my life i want to stop these
addictive behaviors i want to stop being
in bad relationships
now is the time to like take that step
if not now
when and the thing that better help is
really cool is that they
really cool i like to make sure i get
real specific i know it's
really awesome that they match you up
with uh they match up with like
professionals that match
your needs which is the hardest part
about finding somebody to talk to is
you're like
i don't really vibe with that person
they don't understand what i'm talking
about they don't get what's
like i have female problems i want a
female i want a male
there i want to talk about sex stuff i
want to talk to someone you know like
just
you should be able to choose see that's
cool right the person you want
very cool thanks for the specific
adjectives benton i was thinking more
like helpful
salubrious a word we all use
better health wants you to start living
a happier life today
therapy is a very complicated
uh thing to have to schedule and book
and drive and get there they take
all of the stress out of something that
should be it's on your time yeah it's
supposed to alleviate stress
and better help has figured that out
it's also more affordable than
traditional
offline accounts yeah and financial aid
is available which is really important
that's amazing because sometimes our
biggest problems come from financial
insecurity
all of our problems visit betterhelp.com
whitney that's better help h-e-l-p
sometimes we talk too fast
and don't say that and you guys think
it's better heap and you're googling
better heep what's better heap
betterhelp.com join the over 1 million
people taking charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
i'm available they close the website
i'm absolutely available just fyi
special offer for good for you listeners
they get 10 percent
off your first month at betterhelp.com
whitney you love brooklyn
dude i am a plush bitch
i like the finer things in life
getting out of the shower oh grabbing a
brooklyn and towel
wrapping it around your bosom listen
they are nice towels they're i'm just
they are fluffy and comfortable and they
wash really well which is very important
oh because i
had italian wash and it just shrivels up
at the end or
it this stuff doesn't wash out of it
because it's such low quality and what i
do is after i put my makeup on
i then wipe my hands with all the
foundation on it
onto the towels it's a shocking
experience
it looks like did you did you shit on
these cameras
is that placenta and so
everything washes out of it which is
probably not something that brooklyn is
trying to lead with and they keep their
their their like
absorbency and their sausages they don't
become sandpaper
all of a sudden i feel like a princess
there's like that moment when you get
out of the shower it's like
in the morning you're like rushing
you're like trying to get on with your
day
and then your towel sucks so it hasn't
wiped off all the
and then you're hot you're cold and then
you put your clothes on
and you're still wet and now your
clothes are damp and you're just like
it's just like the worst feeling there's
nothing more annoying than a towel that
doesn't actually dry off your body
and these towels work and then walking
wrapped in your tail walking to your
brooklyn
sheets so that like the stalker that's
looking through your window is like damn
she has good taste in towels yeah i
can't kill her she's luxury
the sheets i mean who's more who
who cares more about sheets than me i
don't know
but i know that these sheets have made
me like sheets but also i'm excited to
wash the sheets and put them back in 35
of your life in your bed you spend more
i spent
98 of my life in bed i'm just saying
like you have to your sheets
they when you go to bed at night your
sheets are the last thing you hit and
when you wake up in the morning
you start your day on the right foot it
took me
38 years to realize that the most
important investment you can make
are good sheets yeah you want to improve
your living faith and impress people
just get a nice pair of sheets and
impress yourself when you lay down you
shouldn't be getting
you know like um rug burn from your
sheets and nothing makes me feel better
than walking in my bathroom and seeing
that shelf of matching towels
i am like martha stewart what am i the
queen
of the verse oh magazine this month
what's happening
and then i go to my bed and i'm like a
puffy white comforter
jesus do i host an e-news segment who am
i
drake i must be on the real housewives
this house is luxurious
but that isn't what that is like such an
important part of like building
self-esteem
is investing in self-care items and
investing in the things that only you
benefit from
spending money on all sometimes trust me
only i benefit from my bad i'm just
saying
only things that you see we spend a lot
of money on crap
to try to impress other people spend
money impress yourself
see what happens see how your life
changes when you have a
sexy pair of sheets in your bed watch
out watch how your life transforms
watch all of a sudden nobody's good
enough for you i mean they have it all
brooklyn is the perfect place to find
all the comforts for home
including ultra soft towels they're so
confident in their products that
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty well i didn't know that
shocking use promo code whitney for 10
percent off your first order of
brooklyn.com
that's brooklyn and
e b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n dot com promo code
whitney brooklyn and everything you need
to live your most comfortable life
so sometimes if you're in a relationship
and it's bringing up feelings like you
can just
thank them for like you know
helping you work through unresolved shit
so i think that's what that was but also
like
yeah i ever when someone's healthy
and not in constant communication with
me because they're not
addicted or not obsessed or not
infatuated
i feel rejected and abandoned and it's
so fucked up because
we've talked about this before like if
someone was is too smothering up top
then i never trust the intimacy because
i'm like well you're like this with
everyone
you're just kind of a sex addict or like
this is just my defenses
and then like it doesn't feel special
and
as soon as you're out of my sight i'm
just gonna think you're doing this to
someone else
i i know that you're gonna if we don't
hang out for the weekend i'm like well
it takes it only takes them like a
couple days to fucking be
super close to somebody right so if they
move quickly in the beginning
dating me i'm just thinking if you move
if the person you're with moves too
quickly with
you right then you're always questioning
them because you're like well they move
quickly with everybody
right and they're gonna move quickly
when i go out of town with someone else
interesting like yeah you want someone
to move really slow
in the beginning so that when you're
together you don't have to worry about
them when you're not
with each other i think yeah even though
it can be fucking painful
right yeah i mean i feel that way i
think i feel that way more sexually but
that's probably just like old religious
stuff where i'm like
that was something they said is like in
church where they're like if somebody
has sex with you before they're married
to they have no self-control and you're
like what
but i think there's there's something in
that
12-date thing where you do feel like a
false sense of intimacy if
you maybe sleep with someone you like
really quickly if you're that type of
person you can't think everyone's like
that but i think
we i look i am how long do you wait to
have sex with somebody
if you want to date them i usually the
shortest amount of time i've waited is
like a month
mm-hmm so yeah i mean that's good that's
good that's pretty i've only
i've only had sex with like one person i
didn't
love yet and i hated it interesting what
i've realized recently about myself is
like every relationship i've had
for the most part has been a reaction to
my last relationship interesting
that's why you have to take time off
after your day yes you do need to date
here's my here's what i think i think
when you first start dating someone you
like
you should start dating other people
interesting okay
so if i on monday and you have to have
plans with your girlfriend so if on
monday
you have a date with someone you really
like the next two nights you should have
plans with girlfriends
that you do not fucking cancel and then
a date with another person even if you
don't like them that much
to take the pressure off right and so
that you're not putting all your eggs in
one basket and you're not putting
everything on them
and then you can see them again like
four days later this whole
i i'm not saying it's right i know i
loved the movie blue valentine i would
love to be able to meet someone and just
fucking spend
play yooka-laylee in the road so yeah
it's just yeah that's
four days straight it's just not healthy
you overdose on somebody like if you
really like someone you should not spend
too much time with them
the like first week that you're meeting
and hanging out this whole like we go
out on a monday and then we say hang out
till three in the morning and just like
talk about the universe and then
what are you doing tomorrow and then you
have meet up at five and then you have
dinner and then you're and then the next
day you have brunch and you're hanging
out until
it's just you're gonna start resetting
each other because you're gonna start
giving things up and you're not gonna go
to the gym and you're not gonna be
eating well and you're not gonna be
hydrating
and you're not giving it a fair shot
because you're overdosing you're over
saturating yourself with the other
person you have to tease it out move
slow
yeah i think that means listen to me i'm
38 and single i know what i'm talking
about
she did it um no i
i don't ask you for marriage advice i go
to ron funchess thank you
that's why i ask for advice that's the
num but that is the number one mistake i
see people making is they just move too
fast and they can they like it has bad
pr like
they market it as like you know or
perceive it as like passion or soul
mates and all that shit like if you're
passionate about somebody
and your soul mate with them like they
can wait three days if it's so meant to
be
yeah i will say i don't i've never been
the type of person who has like
the bandwidth to date more than one
person at a time
i just don't know how i could do that
like you have to just
go on a date just to take the pressure
off that person but i think that's just
being fine on your own and being really
busy and being happy with work
so there's not a lot of pressure work or
friendships or something
absolutely i think that's true i'm
agreeing with you and i think that what
um uh part of this
uh aforementioned coven that i'm
developing of all these like girl
friendships is for the first time in my
life i'm experimenting with
how to get my experiments you guys
do you hear her this is like this is
what it's like to be friends with
whitney everyone's on her instagram like
oh my god giving me life
all these girlfriends we're an
experiment
at her house it's just her putting us in
her swimsuits
taking photos of us to see how long it's
gonna take for us to become
addicted to her wait until i start
mining you for your organs
truly she's like she's training
us to be surrogates she made us do
laps last time we were here she's like
now everyone pretend they're having
contractions
it's a fun game i just want to make you
guys a wrench so that you can take care
of me
i'm gonna develop a cult and start just
commissioning you whoever holds their
breath the longest gets to come on my
podcast
[Laughter]
you're a lot thank god
but like you're the best but also oh my
god we're looking fermenting anyway
you're experimenting with friendship i'm
just experimenting with
how to get my emotional needs met
other ways besides relationships with
men
because my whole life it's you have
girlfriends you have work but as soon as
a man comes along
you brush them all to the side right and
your man
has to service 100 of your emotional
needs
interesting has it worked out so well
that's what you've been doing
that's what i was sort of programmed to
do what did you talk to about that guy
men come first my therapist or my
or him i need to talk about you to you
yes i would routinely go to the problem
for the solution i thought if you got a
fight with your man
you go to your man to deal with that no
you go to your girlfriends you go to
your program you go
a 12-step program you go to your
therapist or whatever it is you don't go
to the problem for the solution
i didn't know that right i did not you
have sisters i think you probably have a
healthier relationship with women than i
did i didn't have
a healthy association with women for a
really long time
and then a lot of my friends were guys
and i
thought for a while like oh the best way
to get advice about guys is from guys
which i still believe
in a lot of ways um but i also had
inauthentic friendships i had the
girlfriends that wouldn't give me good
advice they would be like
i think he just likes you too much right
like his phone's probably broken
like that type of shit now i have
girlfriends that are like yeah
it's not working you know they'll tell
me the truth they're not scared of me
so i think for me i'm in a big
reorganization moment in my life like
you talked about losing friends earlier
we talked about this a lot on the
podcast like
i think we have to update our software
every year
and make sure the same way we update our
phones
our computers like is this still the
best version of my friend's circle is
this still the best version of my
you know professional circle like you
just have to refresh every now and then
and i think that i'm going through a
little bit of a
sort of i'm molting interesting and
trying to have more female friendships
in my life especially with equals that's
the other thing
a lot of times why am i here yeah it's a
great you're failing
um uh i think the stronger your
relationships are with good girlfriends
the better your romantic relationships
are gonna be because you're not gonna
try to get all your needs met from that
person
even though i think it's my instinct at
least my programming to
as soon as a man comes along your
girlfriend's see at the wedding
you're my bridesmaids see you in a year
and a half yeah i don't have that
i think i lean on my girlfriends a lot
when i'm in a relationship
i see them less because you always see
people less when you're in a
relationship
yeah but yeah i mean i'm going to be
leaning
i'm going to be leaning on someone for
my emotional needs so let's divvy this
up i do though feel like sometimes you
do
go engage with a partner more than you
should yes oh i think that's absolutely
true going to the problem for the
solution yes
that's something i think about a lot
that you've said and i think because i
think about you sometimes and
i never would have known this at 26 or
so wildly
ahead of me so none of this should feel
disparaging but like
it took me so long to realize that
silence is the only language men
understand
and vice versa with women men with women
too like you cannot dignify certain
things with a response
right and i think that because you're so
smart
and you're emotionally very mature that
we think that if we're just more clear
and direct the other person's childhood
will change
oh there's a quote for you it just
doesn't work that way and i think that
we're at this
this self-help moment with instagram and
podcasts and stuff we're like oh my god
i know how to express my feelings and
like i know how to talk through things
and i'm so emotionally mature and i'm
gonna
mean what you say say what you mean
don't say it mean and i'm not just
because you're
being clear with the person and direct
and mature doesn't mean the other person
has the
mental equipment to receive what you're
saying right well and just because
somebody's aware of something doesn't
mean it's going to change overnight and
the same way that just because we're
aware of our shit doesn't mean that
we're going to handle everything
perfectly like
think about how much we talk like well
this is what it is and it's our
attachment style yeah
and then we meet someone we really like
that that doesn't make their dad have
said i love you two exactly
it doesn't our self-awareness hasn't
fixed us why would it fix someone else
say it again
our self-awareness has not fixed us why
would it fix someone else yes sir
we fixed the sound it doesn't magically
fix things i think it's taken me so long
to just realize that like time takes
time
and knowing the solution for you
doesn't fix everything yeah and
you know it's so interesting because for
the men listening i think this is
important
too because this is going to make you
like me more um i'm about to lose all my
female subscribers but
it's taken me so long or i think women
so long in general to like find our
voice
and be able to stand up for ourselves
and be able to set boundaries and to be
able to like
be strong women or whatever that means
but like now
i'm saying you found your voice great
now stop using it
stop talking so much just stop like
half of what you just like cut
everything you want to say in half and
then
cut it in half again like it's just just
don't say it
you can't take back you can't take it
back yeah once you've said it
and the more you say the more shame
you're gonna feel later that it didn't
work
yeah and that is what erodes your
self-esteem and your self-worth
right is i just said all this stuff and
it didn't work
now i'm embarrassed now i've failed
yeah did you know what i'm saying right
i wasn't enough like that's what i've
learned in the last year
in relationships is like someone else's
actions don't have anything to do
with me or my they not that they don't
have anything to do with me but they
don't have anything to do with my
worthiness you know and i think i always
thought like oh if i were prettier or if
i were better
or if they liked me more they wouldn't
have treated me that way
and that's not true at all because maybe
by the way and maybe they would have
treated you better
and that would have been even worse if
you were prettier and they treated you
better because of that
that would have been even worse right
but they wouldn't have i mean that's the
thing
it's like it's not that they were like
be careful what you want you might get
it
right it's not like people are sitting
there going like i've just met i have so
many like hot
cool successful girlfriends who dudes
just like
who do just like mistreat
or like don't treat correctly or can't
get out of their own way to be with
and you're like oh because they're
attracting shallow guys because they're
hot
no no some of them are good dudes and
they just are like why couldn't he have
done this one thing for me like i have
an
ex who i'm like still best friends with
and
our only issue in our relationship is
that like his work ethic wasn't very
good
and i was just like i can't like get
past this
he was unattractive and like he's
acknowledged it now he's got like a
great job now and he's really like
you know he was like driving for uber
and i was just like dude i can't like do
this i'm outgrowing this
and now he's in a totally different
place and we're like very good friends
and we had a car okay you're like
already
already a cat um
but over black which was literally our
only
thing and like i remember i said
jokingly like a couple years afterward
like well i guess you were never gonna
get it together for me and he was like
it had nothing to do with you like these
are the reasons i finally got it
together
and it wasn't the girl i was with next
yeah and it wasn't because i didn't want
to be with you forever like
it was just my own thing it was never
going to happen at that time
this was bad timing and you never want
someone to do something for you you
won't do it for and they will resent you
and now you're their mom and now it's
incest yes
exactly exactly so that that's been very
freeing for me
because i don't have to take everything
so personally anymore it can just be
something
that you know doesn't serve me where i
just go okay that's something that isn't
going to work for me
yeah in a relationship and it's not
anything
necessarily that makes them a bad person
or me
not hot enough yeah yeah it just is what
it is and that's where you're at and
it's where i'm at yeah
and that's not compatible and that's
fine yeah so like taking all i mean this
is what mood stabilizers will do for you
guys
the difference in me after getting on
mood stabilizers which is why he's crazy
what's it called uh i'm on lamictal okay
i think it's a mood stabilizer i tried
to get on antidepressants what's a mood
stabilizer i don't know how is that
different from an antidepressant
i mean i was told stabilizer i know it's
i mean i mean i'm also taking an
antipsychotic that they're like you can
also use this to sleep like as needed to
sleep
and i'm like is this a trap a mood
stabilizer that's i mean
it's but don't we want different moods i
mean
i mean you just don't want to be so like
this
i don't like up and down i i'm sorry
that i'm
uh i'm just going to play devil's
advocate okay a little bit
because i'm not i'm not a i know this
might come as a shock to you but i'm not
a doctor
yeah dude i know i'm just you see a
psychiatrist i'm surprised as you are
i have a psychiatrist that i see once
every like three months right i went on
prozac
yes because i've been in um uh
cognitive therapy and al-anon 12-step
programs
i always want to qualify this by saying
not all therapy
is good just because you're in therapy
doesn't mean you're sane
right sometimes therapy makes people
worse some therapists are bad some
therapists
i've been to therapists that i i felt
you're just trying to keep me sick so
that you keep me or they weren't
offering solutions like emdr
12-step programs like if you have
addictive behaviors and no one is
recommending 12-step programs get the
fuck away from that therapist
um a lot of times talking about
something too much
re-embeds the trauma and strengthens
a false narrative and it's not healthy i
mean the reason i
love my therapist that she'll she takes
a very neurological approach to go you
need to stop talking about this for 30
days
wow you need to stop apologizing for 30
days like you're not allowed to complain
for 30 days like she really wants
to retrain my neural pathways she's like
you need to do this workbook you need to
write this you know it's like
it's actually about getting better she's
like my goal is for you to stop seeing
me
right if you're still seeing me in five
years i've bad at my job right
you know that's her sort of thing so i
think it's important to just and also
when i first went into therapy it made
me
worse for lack of a better word um if i
may be so inelegant
because i became arrogant because i was
like and i thought i was better than
everyone because i'd be like well i'm in
therapy so i must
be right well i'm the one that's in
therapy right you know i'm in therapy so
i feel like
right you should i'm you know
it made me uh arrogant i go to therapy
and i'm like
am i a narcissist and they're like no
we're fine
yeah like well narcissists would never
ask if they're narcissists right and
that's
what they said my therapist was like
you're fine and also i talked to your
psychiatrist and
she doesn't think you are either like
they've like i've asked that too
i asked my therapist i said do you think
i'm a psychopath
do you think i'm a sociopath and do you
think i'm a narcissist i've done this
many times
right uh and she's like and do you think
i have borderline personality disorder
oh i did that too
yeah and she would and she's just like
people with borderline personality
disorder don't come to therapy
and ask if they have it yeah they number
one wouldn't be in this room
because they any criticism to them feels
like an attack it's too much for them to
handle and narcissists don't acknowledge
that they have weaknesses so they
wouldn't
be like do you think i have a problem
right they'd be like i'm the best i
don't need to go to therapy they
wouldn't be in the therapy
right exactly you know but just because
someone's in therapy
doesn't mean they're healthy mentally
yeah and therapy doesn't work for
everybody
look at us bangs pink hair we're a
fucking mess
dude um i do think it's important like
i do think moods are important like well
yeah
i think it's taken me so long to realize
that like happiness serenity whatever
that means doesn't mean an absence of
negative feelings it doesn't mean
things that hurt shouldn't hurt things
that hurt should hurt
yes but you should be sad sometimes
that's an appropriate like a lot of
people
yeah with the pandemic like i have
anxiety it's like you should
it's not a numbing agent it's a mood
stabilizer i just
there's a difference between like i'm
really sad i'm crying today and
i'm disassociating and i feel like i'm
in a dream and i don't know what's
happening and i'm panicking and i don't
feel real and i'm scared i'm gonna hurt
myself like there's a huge difference
yeah
and now i'm in the former nice great
which is now you're like
the feelings i'm feeling are appropriate
yes exactly like i still
feel everything this was something my
friend told me when i was like i don't
know if i can get on antidepressants she
was like
honestly like i was like do you just
feel good all the time now and she goes
no i still get really sad
i still panic i still feel anxious she's
like but i don't feel like
i'm not going to get through it now
she's like now i feel like i can handle
it nice
but i still feel all those things it's i
think that it's like
people antidepressants and these
medications it's like
are your reactions appropriate yes like
does the punishment
fit the crime right it's that it's like
if you
if i spill this off the counter and
start hysterically screaming and crying
there's something going on if i spill it
and go ah fuck
that's a healthy reaction yeah if if
someone dies and you're sad
you're not depressed right you should be
there's this like
a little bit of a war on anxiety and
sadness that i think is
often conflated with actual clinical
depression like
we all feel entitled to be happy all the
time and that's not
that is not how our brains should work
right
before you decide to go on medication or
therapy or whatever first make sure that
you're not surrounded by
shitheads uh-huh do you know what i'm
saying yeah i spent a long time being
like i'm such a mess and i was like no
my friends are just assholes
right that are late and selfish
and make me feel bad about myself and
that right that are
sort of make me um question my
self-worth like
make sure you're surrounding yourself
with dope people before you diagnose
yourself as the problem
if you're surrounded by dope people and
you still feel anxiety and stress and
now okay this is a me problem right
before you solve a problem first make
sure it's your problem
right you know what else i realized
about our relationship one of the
reasons you probably feel close to me
and one of the reasons you have done so
much for me
is because when we met you didn't feel
like and you're right about this that i
wanted anything from you and in fact was
very anxious about
giving you any indication that i wanted
anything from you
even like just your time and i've felt
that way about people
who whatever open for me or or whatever
like people that i
do the most for are people who have
never made me feel
like they wanted anything from me yeah
except like to get to know me or
whatever
i have an interesting take on that and i
think it's helpful for people
to know this which is that if you're
hiring
when you're a boss when you're trying to
figure out who should be in your life
uh professionally personally i think
it's very important to see
someone's it's going to sound like an
insult
just said something nice just hold for
it
i think it's very important to see
someone's like flaws right away
if you leave an exchange with someone
you're like well that person just has it
all together
and like i see that that's what's
alarming to me
like um i like to see everything up
front because i like to
i don't like to feel like i've been
played or like i'm
acting or like i'm engaging with
someone's
false self or mask interesting it makes
me feel unsafe and uncomfortable like if
you come in and you're like
hey i don't really like you that much uh
like or
something shitty i'm like at least i
know what i'm dealing with i don't care
what you are as long as
it's honest right i can handle any i can
handle
anyone's authentic self but i can't
handle someone's um
false self that's interesting because i
feel like you can be friends with people
you don't fully trust
in a way that i can't interesting but i
accept
their flaw i i go this person's not
trustworthy i don't tell them this and
this and this i
radically accept their nature wow and
then i decide whether or not
i i'm the idiot if i confide in someone
who i know isn't trustworthy i know that
this person is codependent
so it's like there are people in my life
that are like girlfriends or something
and i know they're unrecovered
codependents
interesting i know that they will tell
one of my secrets to someone else in a
fucking heartbeat
right because they're insecure and they
want to trauma bond with that person or
they need to snitch or they have some
shame addiction or they just might think
it's fine to talk to people you've told
people stuff about me that i told you
that i have to tell you that yeah that i
had to be like can we not talk about
that in front of people
but you're but i didn't know did i not
know but you should have known i feel
like
you should have known that is the crux
of her in a relationship
that's you with every guy you should
have known what i was thinking
you should have known not to share it
with me i now i do
i learned that i learned that i said
okay if i tell you that
so i shared information about it so
other people are gonna know that yeah
on social media i just i didn't share it
i just posted it
you told you told people something that
had happened to me recently
that i that they knew the day they met
me
and they were like oh so this happened
and i was like okay
i took five days to tell whitney that
happened oh and i was like
okay my i take sometimes
i don't want to lie i lied for so long
about so much and i kept so many
people's secrets for
but it wasn't i know this is mine this
is totally my fault yeah yeah
and i'm sorry it's okay that's the thing
though we have the type of relationship
where i can go
hey can we not do that you're like my
bad got it i should have known that
totally yeah which is
i fucked up yeah um which i also feel
like
i would do so i feel like we have that
which i makes
and also the fact that you can come to
me and say can you not do that
that's fucking huge yes yes not that it
should have come to that but still
but yeah and you were you know it was
one of those things where like
we're in this business where everybody's
kind of just telling everybody
everything all the time yeah yeah and
we're all about every business i think
that's right
yeah yeah yeah but i think that i also
it's tricky because i do still struggle
with the
i i'm not good at lying i'm just rusty
like i used to be so good at it because
i used to lie so much
now i'm just like i'm just bad at it
right and people will know right but i
also
think it's really important to develop
the skill to be able to say you know
what
it's it's inappropriate for me to chime
in on that right or
when people are gossiping about someone
to go just i don't know enough about the
situation to weigh in
yeah or i don't have an opinion on that
or like it's none of my business and i
just i'm not judging you guys for
talking about it but i just truly
i just don't want to say anything like
right learning that you can
say that and that just because other
people want information doesn't mean you
have to give it to them it's taken me a
long time to go like
me not participating in gossip doesn't
mean i'm a bitch
i just you know it's just not
appropriate for me to share
totally and i've completely done that
with people where i just like say things
before i realize like or i just assume
people already know things or they're
gonna know something yeah
yeah so it's like yeah it doesn't matter
if i say this and then you go ah shit i
shouldn't have done that yeah
it's so i'm just so afraid of lying i'm
like i think i'm
too so afraid of lying nobody else's
that i ever
share we both over share because we're
afraid of not being authentic yeah
nobody else is worried like i'll go i'll
be talking to the guy that i'm dating
and i'll be like
just so you know i dated this doctor
when i was in philly and he's like what
like i don't right like
i just so like yeah omissions are not
lies
right lies and omissions are not the
same thing unless somebody says
i need to know something for this reason
i think it's in a book called
attached
the book called attached by the
science of attachment anxious avoidance
i don't think it's this one but
there's something called the couple
bubble that has really served me in
relationships
successful relationships where it's like
it's called the couple bubble which is
like before we go to a party
you get into the couple bubble it's like
okay what are you insecure about
what am i insecure about and you
approach going to a party or a public
space or a wedding or whatever
yeah like a like a team that's about to
go out and you make a play
which is like okay lindsay's gonna be
there she makes me super insecure so if
lindsay corners me can you make sure to
come help me
and you approach it like um like a team
and like oh mark's gonna be there and
you know i dated mark and i don't care
but like i just
like if i'm around him i'm probably
gonna want to hold your hand so can you
just like put your arm around me
so that we're not going into situations
expecting the other person to read our
mind and yes
know what we need we communicate what we
need before we go in and we're in the
couple bubble
and also i want to leave by 10 o'clock
so we're on the same page about when
we're gonna leave about how much we're
gonna drink okay let's have two glasses
of wine and then let's go to
you know whatever fucking carl's jr
afterwards like and you have a plan so
later
you're not like well i want to fucking
leave it i was ready to leave and you
weren't ready to leave and you had three
glasses of wine and i had one glass of
wine so you were fucking wasted and
having a blast and i was fucking
miserable stuck in the corner with
lindsey
right you know so you have to like like
create a game plan
and that to me is like the most
important tool in a relationship
yes because after every party after
every wedding it's a fight
what the fuck was that you just fucking
talked to john the whole time i was
fucking alone in the corner with the guy
fucking dated two years
like it was just like i just want a
teammate i just want someone on my team
that's it that's it that's all that's it
as soon as you're on separate teams
you're fucked yeah that's why it's hard
to date people who are
very self-focused yeah selfish even if
they're like really good people
if they're just like in their own movie
the whole time yeah
and everyone is just a character and
even if you're like their leading lady
you're still just a character and it's
also if you're arguing with someone or
having a
uh what i like to call a growth
opportunity
nice rebrand a pivoting session
[Laughter]
when i post a picture of me and my
boyfriend on instagram i call it a
marketing meeting
it's a branding experiment um no i i do
like to call
fights or arguments opportunities for
growth i love that
it's better that's really hey i think
there's an opportunity for growth here
should we talk about this
yeah you know yeah uh calling it fights
arguments like it's just
bad uh it's just bad words
yes that makes things seem worse than
they are and make your motives ookie
um but if there's an opportunity for
growth with someone that you're
dating um i think as soon as it's like
i'm fighting with you instead of i'm
fighting for you it's over
yeah it's like if i win we both lose if
i win that means we're against each
other
right so i think it's taking me so long
to realize like hey buddy like
i felt really scared about this thing i
needed to bring it to you i want to talk
to you about it it has to be more like a
uh i'm not a sports person uh what is it
when you get oh doo-wop
what's it when you a hand pal
when you get together with a bunch of
people and you do a a
pow-wow oh it's more of a pow-wow okay
so
it says appropriation like what do we do
i know a pow-wow
it's a pow-wow it's not a fight it's an
argument like it's a pow-wow like yeah
it's like hey dude like if you approach
conflicts
with with your partner like that it's
gonna be so much better
right because no one can fail because no
one can win or lose if you win you feel
like shit
and if you lose you feel like shit but
that's the benefit of oversharing
in the beginning of a relationship if
you overshare and you go this is what i
need
this is why i need it yeah really clear
about it before it's even an issue
you don't have to read my mind and then
that's like just blown past or ignored
that's like hard to get past i think
yeah and i don't know why you guys
wouldn't believe all of this coming from
two single minutes
i mean look both of us could have been
married if we wanted to be
no i have it so it's honestly that's the
thing i just have a very
i'm holding out for a hero and i'm 26 so
it's fine
i'm 67 as well i've been in a
relationship
uh for the last seven years are you
dating now or no no
not for a while i don't want to good
that's right multiple people invite me
to raya i'm good
but are you actively saying i'm not
dating now
to for certain reasons yes okay good
yeah you're taking a sabbatical i am
taking a sabbatical
i love that on everything for how long
you have to put a date on it
um i don't know i mean at least until
january
you should like put a hard date on it
if you put a clock on it and say like
i'm not going to date anyone until
january 1st
okay just or whatever yeah cause then i
really love
scheduling decisions you can always add
later you can always add months later
i'm not even gonna think about this as
an option but you might
cave sooner you might go well i met this
guy and it's been two months so i might
you're gonna
and that is what erodes our self-esteem
when we have a plan
and don't follow through with it and
then we feel weak so the best thing we
can do is set goals and then achieve
them and that builds our self-esteem
so it's like even if a cute guy texts
you it's like text me january 2nd
see you then and the same thing with
making decisions where it's like and you
and i
went through this a lot when we were
scheduling our tour hot segway
um where we were talking about reno and
san francisco november 6th and 7th
we were talking about um covet and and
touring and we were like oscillating on
whether we should tour whether we
shouldn't tour
and i remember us going like let's not
think about this
to like till june 8th right
until then so that we can free up and
liberate our brains to think about other
things and then we can stress
schedule when you're going to stress out
about something yup instead of
generalized stress
all the time just go like in
relationships like
right now dating somebody not sure about
it i'm going you know what i'm not going
to worry about this
till november 1st right until november
1st i'm going to entertain this
i'm going to be in it it because my
instinct i'm very black and white
because i need even a false sense of
control i'll go like fucking i'm out and
the next day i'm like oh you texted me
he's kind of cute i was being ridiculous
yesterday
and then i'm just in madness so i'm like
i'm gonna just
be in until november first and then i'll
decide
i'll make a decision based on the data
i've collected until november 1st
yes because right now i just don't have
enough data yeah not enough data which i
think is just like
a good thing i'm learning when people
like i don't know if this guy's good for
me or bad for him like you just have not
enough data
yeah it's premature yeah i think that's
great you also told me something
recently where you were like you're 26
you don't want to meet
your person right now because you're not
who you are and i was like
you're soulmate then you're gonna be a
different person in two years i know i
know
but and i think it's possible to grow
with certain people and i think a lot of
it's timing and like
i haven't been alone in a really long
time yeah and part of it i think is just
childhood insecurity of like you're
afraid to lose momentum you're like
if i stop dating maybe i won't
know how or i won't be desirable anymore
or something and i finally
feel like i'm in a place where i feel
good about myself which is really weird
yeah and i'm like okay like right after
i came to your life
what a coincidence i whitney came to my
life broke me down again
and i built myself back up and i said
wow i trust me
like you're not religious anymore you
could just call me god and call me god
now jesus has risen
[Laughter]
are you there whitney it's me taylor you
told me to come at two and your front
door is locked
um yeah i just and i think anytime i've
been working on myself which is this is
so sad
i was working on myself to be better for
somebody
[Applause]
i was like oh my god dude i i can't
believe you just said that i
i cried last night i cried yeah hard why
didn't you facetime me i needed to do it
because you know i want to watch you
that's a really good i should have
i know i i i do go back and forth with
you of how much weakness i want to show
you
please show me more that would be great
but um
i yeah i know i feel a little bit of
pressure around you to be like strong a
lot to be like
this everything you're doing is working
you're this oh no i know it's not like
i see your flaws like you see my flaws i
think we both see each other
wow what would you think uh for someone
listening
would they find surprising that you know
about me ooh
surprising that they know it's a
surprising thing that you didn't know oh
that you can be very
toxic while dating someone while doing
someone
yeah yeah yeah you can be super toxic
and you seem like somebody who would
just be really like
no i'm gonna take a step away but here's
the good news i don't bring it to them
i hide it from them now and i go through
it on my own five years ago i would have
taken my toxicity to them
interesting now i take it to my
girlfriends and let them okay
help me through it yeah and then they
would never know about it
right unless they listen to the podcast
which is
a nightmare right it's hide it you have
to just protect them from your but i've
seen you play games
i've seen it happen and yeah and you
told me
you're like you have to do this you just
have to play this game and i'm like
i don't think it's this it's this
there's a difference between playing
games
and acquiescing to human nature
so when i say like you can't respond to
that text let him spin out a little bit
i'm not saying
play games it's just don't do his work
for him he's doing something immature
but the time you're talking about where
you're like i'm gonna let him spin out
he was being so mature with you he was
being so direct so mature and you
decided it wasn't what you wanted to
hear
and so you were like he fucked up he
fucked up i'm going for a walk he fucked
up and i'm like i don't think he did
but then i needed to take a walk and i
needed to process the i did thank god i
didn't respond
right with something emotional or punish
or punitive or you did
you did respond and i said something
kind of petty oh and confusing
and then he tried to call you and you
were like and i was like
talk to this person but you cannot
engage if you're
in an emotional you weren't an emotional
i made a mistake then yeah you were in
an emotional place but yes you did work
through it on your own yeah you're
correct
but i just wouldn't have expected any of
that yeah because this is someone that
kicked up by inner child
yes yes yes yes but then you've seen me
with someone that is just a
relatable oh yeah and then you with
someone who's super available to you is
so sad so bad for that guy
he's like such a nice dude all right we
have to go because we're taking kova
test because
in order to fly to uh uh take our flight
we have to
i i didn't know about this you have to
we have to present our
cova test um i think in order to like
work when we're i think it's just
is it just boston is it just uh
massachusetts um i think
technically it's new york too they make
you sign something when you land that
says you have to quarantine for
two weeks um
unless you well that's because we're
proving that we took a cover test oh
okay
so i guess this is the way around that
so we'll show up with a piece of paper
that's interesting
yeah i haven't done it so i don't know
but
um i'm trying to look at all of the
things that i didn't ask you that oh
yeah i'm so excited
to go to this i have a yeah i would love
to hear the list
oh this is what it is i was because
after i was my crying spell last night
uh i was trying to think about what it
was and i realized that when i
like somebody i get really emotional and
sad
yeah because it's ultimately like you
have to figure out why you're in pain
and what the pain is coming from
it's my ultimately goes down to my fear
of being embarrassed
yes when yes when you like someone it's
embarrassing
humiliating embarrassment is this most
terrifying thing to me
right and i i you might not even get
this reference because you're too young
but
the movie carrie i've seen carrie oh
really
i always feel like not not the carrie
underwood documentary
the movie where um at the end she gets
wins prom queen and then the they played
a prank on the blood
goes on her head oh that's what it is
i'm not waiting for the other shoe to
drop i'm waiting for the pig's blood
no that's it embarrassment and so for me
when i text a guy this is why i'm so
careful when i text
because i know we talked about this if
you're gonna send a text
play out the rest are you gonna be
waiting for the response or you're gonna
that's part of the reason i'm so stingy
with my communication to someone i like
because i know
i try to like plan okay i'm gonna text
him at eight because then i have nothing
to do afterwards and
i'm not gonna be waiting for a response
yeah do you know what i mean like i try
to
like protect my future self
and being careful when to try to avoid
feeling embarrassed
if i don't hear back or something
embarrassment comes up um
which is a very deep primal fear of like
being
embarrassed maligned castigated
and ultimately in your reptilian brain
like
you don't have the protection of the
tribe i mean it's like a very
deep fear right it's like cellular yeah
like it's like
it like anyway yeah that was a question
for me
that was something
so you're embarrassed right now tell us
right i just figured you'd be there i
feel great
just wearing that shirt you're pretty i
love that you could take it
you can handle it yeah because i don't
respect you
anymore it was actually when we were
pitching this tv show the first
there were we had like five pictures or
something and i would like make fun of
taylor i'd make fun of taylor the whole
time and like
and then say how great brandon was the
whole time by the last
by the last pitch she goes okay so this
is whitney's
thing this is literally like we're on
with the head of hulu and it's so clear
that we like have some like resentments
to work out and she's like all right
this is whitney's thing
she'll like roast me and then say how
great i am it was like
they were like and then she talks about
how talks it is to be partnered with
older people in hollywood
as if that's not what i'm a victim of
right now with her
it was so like like someone walking in
it like you know when you're
at like uh somewhere and a couple is
fighting and it's like so awkward for
everybody else
right oh yeah and i think they enjoyed
it everyone's like mommy and daddy's
fighting
no because i also think it's so
important
uh they see that you stand up to me yes
that's what there's no point in having
there's no point in having your voice on
the show if
i'm not here right if it's not clear you
if you're
if you're just scared of me they're
gonna be like well is taylor's voice
really getting in the show
or is whitney steamrolling her true and
i used to be scared of you and i'm not
anymore literally yeah you had no
questions for me wow
you literally had nothing no i did
i don't think you did you just talked
about you crying for another 10 minutes
and my question was why didn't you call
me
well my big question is uh what's going
on with your hobbies my hobbies i don't
think you have enough hobbies
i don't i really don't you don't have
any non-work related hobbies and it's
worrying me
that's true um your hobbies are like
taking cover okay
says the woman who literally films
everything for instagram stories
i'm sorry it's called bidneth
i rescue dogs that's true you do
and i rehabilitate horses i mean this is
like from a huge
intervention for my therapist was like
you need to do
two hours a week i'm sorry four hours a
week twice a week for two hours a week
non-related work hobbies that's just
play right
i see my sisters and my friends that's
good but not about getting smarter not
about getting better because to me i'll
turn any hobby into a job
right i'll be like i'm going to read a
book for my hobby and then it has to be
like
yeah i have a science book where i'm
getting smart yeah where i was like
we're reading all these self-help books
let's just do a podcast like i literally
yeah but that's not that's not just for
fun what do you do that's what i'm
saying i don't
what's your fun i don't know i've just
been watching tick tock lately
but i wrote a bit of work that's where
yeah that's true
it's me watching it going okay how do i
get better at this what are other people
doing i don't
have anything oh god i don't have
anything i was there i was there i mean
i remember and i was like i'm gonna like
sew blankets and like do crochet and i'm
start doing crochet and i'm like i
should sell these on etsy like
i can't just do something for fun and
for free right
so your horse is for fun yeah i mean
even rescuing is a job though so i
wouldn't give you that
it's not a job i don't get i lose money
rescuing animals okay all right
but i do post about it because it helps
them but it's not my business i don't
mean you're making money like i
lose work off of rescuing animals
everyone thinks i'm crazy but you're
doing a
it is work what you're doing it's hard
what you're doing you know but you know
it's rock
climbing rock climbing is still a hobby
even though it's hard okay that's true
all right i'll give it to you all right
all right fair so
you're right about everything that was
my i take it back thank you okay clip
that
that's going to be the clip just her on
a loop
no but like so do you have any
suggestions for me for hobbies
because now i have time that's another
reason but you will be a better artist
if you have hobbies i know i think a lot
i think a lot of the kind of high
performers the kind of people that
listen to
podcasts like this and the people that
are trying to hustle hustle hustle in
order for art to imitate life you have
to have a life
if you guys have any suggestions for
hobbies please send them please
i did want to kind of start uh gardening
yeah you could yeah i would do gardening
and like growing shit
is fun for me i love that for me i'm too
poor
um okay we love you guys is there
anything else you want to say um
this was fun this was fun wasn't this
good yeah i feel like this was good
this is i feel like if i if this podcast
existed when i was 22
i would have be married by now yeah
i feel like if i didn't know you i would
listen to this podcast
like this is a banger yeah i listened to
some episodes of this
but i have to have like not seen you
that way but this is like a
this is like a wisdom dump this one oh
yeah
this is the way this is a wisdom dump
and i don't think we over shared too
badly
are you gonna i mean you can go back and
edit cutting all everything i set out
um yeah no there's definitely a uh this
was definitely a banger
yeah this is definitely like a share a
share it i mean we'll see
what the numbers are yes be honest
i will see who got more views than me on
youtube
hillary duff is killing her oh i'm sure
she is killing in the numbers
she's so good um all right we love you
guys uh see you on tour san francisco
and reno and whatever other dates i
force
uh taylor to add love you don't ride
elephants or dolphins
um and write taylor some positive
comments about her shirt and don't
don't don't tell her i'm bullying her
don't don't enable her i know
don't do that you don't need to tell me
i have to pee so bad
[Music]
[Applause]